i have a figure to show you today that
will make you gasp
exactly
and here it is
well whether you gasped or not we are
going to discuss what this graph is
showing and what that means for further
understanding the aging process
and also maybe what it doesn't
all right so i hope you're hungry
because our story today begins with the
intestine
in particular the large intestine the
large intestine is involved in absorbing
water and absorbing some of the vitamins
from foods and it's also where most of
the gut microbiome is residing
anyhow the functional unit of the
intestine is the crypt
and at least in humans
we have around 15 million of them
like so
and from what i remember from my
undergrads there has previously been
some controversy over the organization
of these crypts but at least for this
video we will go with the simplified
understanding that at the base of these
crypts are a pool of stem cells
stem cells can replicate to make more
stem cells but they can also produce
these transient amplifying cells which
do most of the replication to comprise
the cells of the crypt as you might
expect the large intestine has quite a
high turnover of cells
so since some stem cells will divide to
produce more stem cells whilst others
will divide and differentiate
over time the intestinal crypt becomes
dominated by cells originating from one
stem cell clone it becomes monoclonal
a previous study beautifully illustrated
this phenomenon using different coloured
fluorescent markers as you can see here
and so i don't know if i stole this
analogy but you can sort of think of the
crypt being like a conveyor belt or an
escalator of how the cells progress
but anyway this organization of the
crypt has a unique feature therefore
that due to this domination by a stem
cell as evidenced by these pretty
pictures
all cells in a crypt are derived from a
single ancestral stem cell that existed
in recent years that is to say if there
was a mutation in the stem cell then all
the cells would possess it
because these mutations are found not in
the egg or the sperm the gem cells they
are found in non-germ cells called
somatic cells
mutations in these cells are called
eugastics
the fluids
uh no somatic mutations
and then if you wanted to find out what
the somatic mutations were in the
original ancestral stem cell you can in
theory sequence the dna from any of the
descendants
and so not all mutations are bad i mean
evolution rights
some may be good some may not have any
apparent effect or some yes may be bad
but what if i told you all this
aha well this finally brings me on to
this recent paper from nature which has
already caused a lot of excitement
somatic mutation rates scale with
lifespan across mammals which is a
little bit of a spoiler for what we're
going to talk about but what exactly did
they do in this paper
well quite simply they calculated a
somatic mutation rate for the intestinal
crypt for a variety of different mammals
each with different lifespans from mice
cats dogs humans all the way through to
lions
and this is because as we saw in the
intestine over time we accumulate
mutations even in the world's coolest
protein
and unfortunately some of these
mutations can give rise to cancer
but do they also contribute to aging
well this somatic mutation theory of
aging has been around for a long time
of which the general idea of the theory
is quite simple apparently
this article from 1965 continues
spontaneous mutations are postulated to
occur in the somatic cells of the body
and since they are in general
irreversible their numbers will tend to
curtail some cellular function the cells
will gradually become inefficient or die
as the mutations accumulate
and when this process takes place in a
sufficiently large percentage of the
cells of the body
senescence aging gradually develops
and then this is my favorite bit
the problem with this theory has been
that it has not been possible to test it
because no methods are available for
measuring mutations in somatic cells
well welcome to the year 2022
and at the sangha institute in cambridge
they've now developed many tools that
enable the sequencing of dna from clonal
patches of cells without having to do
whole genome amplification which reduces
the introduction of biases and errors
using small amounts of dna input
and therefore it now enables questions
like these to be addressed
so in this paper they chose the
intestine as a good model for having a
group of cells that possess the same or
almost all the same somatic mutations
which makes sequencing easier and also
the estimation of somatic mutation rates
more trustworthy
so i think the most important figure to
talk about is this one here
and what this graph is showing is how
somatic mutation rate correlates with
lifespan of the different species tested
there is a tight anti-correlation
showing that the lower the somatic
mutation rate the longer the lifespan
so how do they define somatic mutation
rates
while rate is any change in variable
over time so here they calculated it
based on the number of mutations in a
crypt by the age of the individual
then the question is well how do you
define a mutation
so they ran their sequence data through
a variety of algorithms one of which is
the caveman algorithm
and they compare it with non-intestinal
tissue to ignore germline mutations
mutations slash variations present since
birth and to also get an estimation of
this mutation rate they also assumed
monoclonality of the colorectal crop
samples
and so as i won't mention it later they
did find similar mutational patterns
across the species despite them having
different diets and lifestyles and that
most of these mutational signatures
appeared to be endogenous rather than
exogenous causes of mutations
but anyway what important points can we
make about this graph
well the first thing worth mentioning is
pito's paradox this paradox essentially
asks the question why don't bigger
animals have higher cancer rates since
their cells have to go through more cell
divisions and therefore the chance to
accumulate more errors
you know more dna synthesis more chance
of errors right well wrong
if you look at the graph you can see the
giraffe and naked mole rats having
similar somatic mutation rates which
matches their similar lifespan despite
giraffes being 23 000 fold bigger in
body mass
so this suggests the accumulation of
somatic mutations is time dependent not
cell division dependent
but then the thing you might want to ask
is then well why do they have a lower
mutation rate
and one explanation for pito's paradox
is that some species have increased dna
repair
and that's kind of an interesting thing
to further explore especially in
different species to see
how do they repair their dna differently
to maybe what humans do although if you
look at this graph we're looking pretty
good right now
but identifying more efficient dna
repair enzymes could have therapeutic
value
and so we also need to address the
elephant in the room or well lack of it
actually but i mean the elephant size
gap between the data points it would be
nice to see the trends match in other
species or potentially to identify
outliers
and then obviously it would be good to
have a species who live longer than
humans to see if this also fits the
trend
and then it would also be cool to have
finer resolution within a species in
particular in humans
as i think that would also be quite
informative
and then there is correlation versus
causation
this graph shows a correlation but
doesn't mean that mutations are causal
for aging
well there are cases in most studies
where they can increase dna damage and
you see the mice age faster and then
there's cases of human progeria patients
who show you symptoms of advanced aging
and have mutations again in dna repair
enzymes
but that still doesn't really address
the question of well why would mutations
cause aging
and i know that review i mentioned
earlier gave a couple of ideas
but it's worth considering again here
that this study was on in intestinal
cells which replicates and then progress
to the surface of the intestine and then
eventually die
and so there's quite a high turnover of
cells here
but what would be the consequences in
cells that persist longer in the body
like in neurons and would therefore
sematic mutations and neurons also be
correlated with lifespan and different
species
and then lastly here they technically
didn't sequence the full genome sequence
so maybe there were mutational events
that could be informative
and this is because the eight percent of
the genome they missed was only recently
sequenced why this is useful and if
you're interested in what the genome
doesn't tell you then you should watch
this video here so with that i hope
you've learned something in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening